he's one of the best in the business
entering his sixth year now as the lead
back in dallas
from the dallas cowboys ezekiel elliott
how are you zeke i'm doing great how are
you doing i'm doing better for talking
to you here um what is your outlook for
the 2021 season walk me through it as
you're getting ready to
kick things off against the tampa bay
buccaneers on the big thursday night
kickoff um i mean the main goal is just
you know get better weekend week out and
uh you know make a playoff round
well what about you as a player um how
are you different in year six
entering uh the nfl compared to now
um you know i came into the season a
little bit louder than i have in the
past uh
so you know i'm a little bit a little
bit lighter um you know i i did a little
bit different training this offseason i
just work on some of my short area
quickness and change of direction
so i'm just coming into the season uh uh
leaner um quicker and uh
just ready to make an impact
is there such a thing as an ee21 system
anything like that that you got going on
right now like the tb12 system the ee21
system
oh
um i guess you could say that
so what have you done differently then
um you know just a lot more cardio a
little bit less you know strength
like just like heavy lifting just more
uh
more body weight more functional
movement um
just kind of so i can lean out i'm just
be lighter
so how do you think that's gonna
uh affect your play positively like
how how do you think
that's going to give you an edge
this year no i think i think i
definitely have gotten quicker uh you
know this off season so just like my
short area quickness uh
getting in and out of cuts uh getting in
and out of tight spaces so just being a
little more shifty is kill elliott here
uh getting ready to take on the tampa
bay buccaneers what's the the challenge
in taking on the defending super bowl
champs in their house the night they
raised the banner what's your challenge
do you think
definitely the uh the strength of their
defense is uh you know that front seven
uh you know anchored by
you got the the the big d line you got
jpp you got sue um you got a bunch of
guys on the d line they're all pretty
good good players uh then you got the
the linebacker duo uh
so i mean you got you got a really
athletic uh fast
fast uh front seven so i mean we just
gotta neutralize those guys and uh do do
do uh the line of scrimmage yeah levante
david and and and the kid white who has
just been terrific since he's come up
from uh from lsu what do they look like
to you on film
that makes them stand out zeke um i
think the biggest thing to me that that
makes them stand out they're both just
such versatile players um
you know they're guys that you know
they'll put put their hat on you but but
they're also guys that can run from
sideline the sideline uh you know they
could you know make you miss and pass
pro or they can ballrush you so i mean
they're this very well-rounded
very well-rounded uh linebackers and
they play well off each other
so um how does dak look so much of a
conversation about his arm and
and what happened this summer and having
the team
reach out to
other
doctors on baseball teams yankees and
rangers how is he looking to you before
this big kickoff night zeke elliott um
dak looks good he's looked as good as
he's ever looked um he's very focused uh
he's ready um he's ready to go out there
and put his best football on film this
year
so uh what what was it like uh to to
watch him get back on the field how did
that
affect your team to see him get back and
be the dak that you want him to be
just it's just inspirational and you see
like you see the hard work he was
putting in day in day out in the
offseason just to you know get back to
where he was and then kind of have a
little bit of a set or a little bit of a
problem with the back muscle and camping
just for him to you know in the face of
even more adversity just uh you know
rise to the challenge and and work
non-stop uh day in and day out just to
get back to on the field in a full goal
and been able to throw
uh throw the ball so i mean it's just
the inspiration to see his work ethic on
just his determination and and how how
we're facing with diversity he he always
responds
z kelly had here uh prior to kickoff of
the 2021 season the cowboys
and the bucks on westwood one radio so
the the conversation about dak and and
what he's become and obviously the two
of you
growing up together uh in the nfl the
conversation about
uh quarterbacks being ready or not and
being thrown in or not
um justin fields in chicago is one of
the few rookies who's going to be
sitting there and watching to start and
obviously i know you've followed his
career
uh being a fellow buckeye what is your
position what is your thoughts on
watching somebody
get thrown in the deep end of an nfl
pool at the quarterback position whether
they need to sit and watch or what you
think of that whole
conversation that's going on in the nfl
i know it's not your house particularly
but you definitely i'd imagine have an
opinion on this um you know i think it's
just
i think it just varies case the case uh
just depends you know what situation you
know each kid is in it i mean it's a
little if are they in a situation where
they'll have you know a lot of help on
on offense or they're gonna have a bunch
of offensive weapons that can help them
and they don't have to feel like you
know all the burdens on them or you know
is it a situation where they need to
rebuild and you know you know develop
the whole line i love better uh just to
give them more time but i also think
like it just depends on the guy itself
what's his mentality you know um how
long did he play in college uh you know
how many snaps did he get
is he ready
what did you think of what you saw from
uh from your alma mater first week
what'd you think of what you saw against
minnesota zeke did you catch any of that
um yeah yeah i watched i watched the
game uh um you know i think i think it
was week one you know minnesota always
plays really really good especially when
we when we play them at uh at in
minnesota i remember playing there my
sophomore year was a
closer game than that um but uh you know
i think uh just the biggest thing is on
defense we gotta stop the run um but you
know everything else
uh it looked pretty good we were able to
you know i think we were a little shaky
at first but we knocked that off and uh
i think by the second half we were
rolling
what do you think what do you think
urban's biggest challenge is going to be
now he's in hc in the nfl in
jacksonville
irvine's biggest challenge in
jacksonville um going from one level to
the next what do you think
i think maybe just one of the toughest
things for me you know going from the
league or from
ncaa to to pro is just uh
you're gonna lose football games kind of
in college like it's it's like you lose
one game one or two games and now you're
you know you you're out you're out
of contention for the championship uh so
i mean i think in in the league you
gotta you know use those those losses to
to make to grow yourself and because i
mean you're gonna get about five or six
you can get about five or six of them in
a year and still go in super bowl
all right so wrapping this up getting
ready for thursday night kickoff against
the buccaneers ezekiel elliott what is
your what is your goal for this year do
you write goals down
for you personally and try to meet them
how do you go about that what is that
for you in 2021
um i mean my goal in 2021 is just just
uh i don't really pay much attention to
individual goals man i just want this
team
to do the best that they can or that we
can uh you know i want to go deep into
the playoffs i want to you know
make a shot at winning that super bowl
so i mean just weekend week out getting
better as a team and uh you know pick it
at the right time and and going on the
run
so you don't have a certain you know
benchmark it's two thousand euros i mean
i feel like it's weekend week out you
know you get better um you take care of
winning football games i think by the
end of the season you'll have a a pretty
good season
okay you know i mean michael irvin i'd
imagine would say something you know
like you know he's he's the king of uh
of
there's a there's two eyes and michael
and one and two in irvine you know what
i mean one and one and michael two in
irvine so he's he hasn't uh nudged you
underneath that front at all zeke
okay
well look zeke i appreciate the time
thanks greg uh greatly have a great 2021
season let's let's catch up down the
line and enjoy the kickoff okay thank
you you have a good one thank you that's
ezekiel elliott getting ready to kick
things off in the 2021 season for the
dallas cowboys
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here